it happens somewhere here in the forest
on the outskirts of butcher tetiana
sichkar is telling me how a war crime
has devastated her life suddenly I heard
a very loud gunshot so something maybe
it was blood or maybe it was a bullet
she shows me a picture of her and her
mum
the most important woman in her life
and she explains what happened the day
they tried to walk home as Russian
troops occupied their streets and the
Woodland tracks nearby and that shot
rang out I screamed to lay down
and we all fall on the ground
I tried to shake her her leg she didn't
answer her head was all in blood there
was blood everywhere
her eyes were still open and she was
just staring and I started to scream I
screamed for maybe five minutes where do
you think the shot came from my father
believed it because the Russians were
Sarah
the sniper was on the second floor of
that white building behind the trees
Tatiana leads us to the grave of her
mother here it is
miss most
Choice was the closest one to me
but yeah that was hard yeah but it's
hard but it's go goes on
do you think
you will see the person who did this in
a court of law on trial it's very likely
that that person is already dead but if
that person is still alive
I believe that I will see him in the
court and he'll take all the
responsibilities and
maybe I'll ask him what made him do it
to my family
so now she is pursuing Justice regular
meetings with human rights lawyer Oksana
mikhailovich they want Ukrainian police
to Stage a reconstruction next month to
at least establish exactly where the
shot came from so they can perhaps
identify the Russian military unit
involved they will then go after the
commanders
I am sure there should be responsibility
for each crime says Oksana I will not
stop because it is important Tatiana
says she owes it to her family to fight
she will not give up
one grave site one war crime one
destroyed life among so so many here